the diode is our first semiconductor
device and it's a really important one
every other semiconductor is basically
made from combinations of diodes and
here's a picture of a diode that you can
buy this is a just a small little glass
package and that distance right there is
about four millimeters and inside here
right inside here is a little silicon
chip and it's manufactured to be a diode
so the question is what is a what is a
diode a diode is something that conducts
current in one direction and does not
conduct current in the other direction
and the symbol we use for a diode looks
like this it has this big arrow here
that points in the direction of the
forward current that one way to
understand how a diode works is to draw
an IV curve for it so let's let's draw
an IV curve for a diode if it was a
perfect diode made in some unknown
technology what would happen is in the
reverse direction if the voltage across
the diode was negative
we'll call will label the voltage this
way if the voltage across the diode was
negative that is this terminal was at a
higher voltage than this terminal there
would be zero current flowing and then
for any positive voltage basically the
diode would look like a wire so I can
call that that's essentially modeled
model number zero of a diode now what we
build real diodes what happens is we
don't quite get that perfect behavior so
in particular if we drew if we build a
diode out of silicon we can go to a I'll
go to a number one model
and a silicon diode actually doesn't
conduct to a slight positive voltage and
then it would go up like that where this
is around 0.6 volts for a lot of simple
circuits that we build this is a pretty
good IV model of of a diode just as a
reminder when we had the IV curve of a
resistors a resistor IV curve looks
something like this it was a line that
went through zero and had a constant
slope so ended up so a diode so a diode
is a really different kind of device
it's a nonlinear device because we can
see from this let me move up here and
now we'll go to a next level model that
is actually the one I want to talk about
most this is the model of diode that we
use most of the time so I'll call this
model number two this is the model that
you use when you'll simulate circuits or
simulate diodes and we're going to talk
about this a little bit more so when you
have a diode if I gave you a diode like
this and I said what's the IV curve of
it so what I would do is I would I would
find some sort of box that made voltage
for me a power supply with an adjustment
on it and then I would also have
something that read current so this is
an ammeter and this is a voltage supply
and we hooked that up like that what
we're going to do is we're going to
generate this IV curve by making actual
measurements of I and V
so my first v setting is zero that gives
me this point here I hope I measure a
current of zero otherwise this thing
would be generating power which it's not
going to do and then I turn up the
voltage slightly and what I notice is
there's no current there's no current
when it's at point one volts or 0.2
volts and then when it gets to around
0.6 volts on the diode
here's VD and here's when the voltage on
the diode is around 6 volts what I
notice is the current goes up so it goes
up to 5 milliamps and then a little bit
higher it goes up to 10 milliamps like
that and I can plot out all these points
along this part of the curve now I go
back here and I change the voltage here
to read the other way around
and that means I'm traveling this way on
the on the voltage axis and what I'll
read my ammeter will read zero in
milliamps 0 0 0 0 to 0 so that plot in
this part of the line here now if I make
this voltage really large and really
negative say I make this like minus 50
volts that's that's this point here what
happens is I see a really sharp
increasing current like that right there
and it keeps going and that is called
the breakdown VBR is breakdown and for
silicon diodes minus 50 volts is a
typical value for that this graph here
shows a break in the scale so this is
minus 1 volt minus 2 volts and then we
go all the way out to 50 volts minus 50
volts and that's where the breakdown
occurs and most of the time when we're
using diodes we're using them between
plus or minus 1 volt across there their
terminals so that's how the that's how
we know what the IV characteristic of a
diode is and what we can do is actually
for this section of the curve right here
for this part of the curve I can model
this with an equation
and the equation looks like this this is
the IV equation for a diode so this is
sort of like the Ohm's law for a diode
I equals is this is a current times e to
the Q that's the charge on an electron
times V on the diode that's the voltage
on the diode divided by K t minus 1 K is
Boltzmann's constant and T is the
temperature of the device measured in
Kelvin so this equation actually fits
this part of this curve for a real diode
it's a it's a fitting curve will look at
these constants one at a time is is
called the saturation current saturation
current and for silicon for silicon
that's a value of about 10 to the minus
12 amperes which is 1 Pico ampere that's
how much is is Q is the charge on an
electron and that equals one point 602
times 10 to the minus 19 coulombs that's
Q VD is the voltage across the diode K
is Boltzmann's constant that's a small K
usually and that equals one point three
eight times ten to the minus
twenty-three joules per Kelvin
and the last variable is T and that's
the temperature and that's measured in
Kelvin with a big K Kelvin is the
absolute temperature scale so zero
Kelvin equals minus 273 degrees Celsius
very very cold so this right here is the
diode equation that's the diode IV
equation and it has this exponential
shape in it it has its exponential term
in it but when we look over here maybe
this doesn't look like an exponential
curve you haven't seen a curve like that
but that actually is just a trick of the
scale of this drawing so what I want to
do now is I'm going to zoom in really
super close right on this origin right
here and we're going to see how this
exponential term shows up and we'll see
what the meaning of is is
I equals is times e QV over KT minus one
and here's a close up here's an extreme
close up on the origin of the diode
curve the voltage scale is blown up by
about a factor of ten so here's one
tenth of a volt forward across the diode
and the current scale is super blown up
this is in Pico amperes now so this is
in ten to the minus twelfth amperes
instead of ten to the minus three and
you can see here this is a more familiar
looking exponential curve and over here
there's a little bit of an offset
there's a little tiny current in the
reverse direction when the voltage is
negative and this amount here that's is
flowing in the negative direction in the
diode if we look at the diode equation
and you let V go negative what happens
is this term here in the diode equation
becomes very very small compared to one
and what's left is is is times one and
that's what we're looking at right here
this is a really small current as you
can see from the scale here it's down in
the low Pico amps area almost all the
time you can ignore this current and
just treat it as zero now I want to use
a diode in a circuit and we'll see how
how we solve circuits that include these
nonlinear diodes in them